en direct - ont fait 3 contre 3,5 et
pour que quelqu'un gère le micro on peut
remettre ceux du milieu que bonjour à
tous et bienvenue pour cette
gata moi parce que j'ai deux fois mon
bras cassés argent technique je suis pas
préparé on n'est pas ultra préféré c'est
un petit peu à larache mais c'est le
premier lieu je juste loire deux
premiers jeux otv de l'histoire de sa
rolls et le premier jeu tv à ma
connaissance de l'histoire qui soit un
jeu bayésiens est donc aujourd'hui ce
qui va se passer c'est qui va avoir deux
équipes qui vont s'affronter d'un côté
on à valentine flow charge
charles chao à charlotte et de l'autre
côté
pline thibault et desperados voilà
bertrand bertrand de la chaîne les
pluies ces dernières phases électrique
et ils vont s'affronter un qcm bayésiens
sur les barques connaissance de youtube
chacun va avoir une question à faire une
question
tour à tour et chacun va voir un cuisse
donc c'est sûr application beezup
ti rêve pour le web maintenant ce sera
sur mon ordi mais pour ceux qui
voudraient jouer et du tout l'équipe 1
ça va être ça la première question
qu'elle est annoncée
qu'est-ce qui la réponse est non c'est à
pile ou face
j'ai pas de pièces la vidéo ça tombe
d'accord il ya un petit poucet caillou
liés et monsieur fille qui propose de
régler à pierre feuille ciseaux à qui
commence en fait ce d'opposer bertrand à
valentine je pensais que tu froid allait
ou non
hier comment commencer ok le lot cuisez
pas en livre sinon il n'en fait pas il
est là le lien crimes qui n'ont ils pas
là je sais pas attendant live on n'est
pas préparé
alors donc la première question c'est
quelle est la première vidéo de dirt iba
logic est encore visible sur sa chaîne
non non mais
alors c'est eux qui répondent et donc
c'est un qcm
c'est un choix multiples qui a quatre
récompenses possibles et pour chaque
réponse vous mettez des probabilités
donc les quatre réponses sont les fruits
sont des ovaires dégueulasse la science
du ice beckett
gamehope ans versus science la première
évacués de leur typologie donc ça vous
dois rentrer les choses vous donne et il
a passé sept comités 0% quatre mois j'ai
dit entre les jours de la première faq
se soit passé plein de trucs
huawei m on peut mettre 5 % sur la
première à les 20% sur lequel je n'ai
reçu aucun soin quasi sûr quatre pour
mira les raisons du souviens l'avoir vu
sortir responsable sur la première en
suisse et à -5%
je ne sais pas créneau cinq à les
médecins qui font de la première attaque
eu aussi c'est possible
[Rires]
salle édith samaké c'est bien mais
d'hypotension zéro créé dans ce cas si
jamais les leur est sur sa phase normal
voilà ce qu'est 84,5 10,85 que c'est
votre dernière quantification je trouve
qu'il ya là bas on estime qu on a mis à
4 vous avez marqué 9 4 points sur un
maximum de 10 alors passons à l'autre
équipe qui avec l'idée en plus qui a
rejoint l'équipe bonjour quelle est la
première vidéo de sciences étonnante
encore visibles sur sa chaîne réponse un
jules césar
y at il un peu de jules césar dans un
verre d'eau je mets des pierres sur les
jeux a rebondi de la plus grosse erreur
de l'histoire de la physique
on pense troie un programme informatique
imbattable au poker réponse 4 le libre
arbitre et gustative jeu césar 97% et
experte chrono de 5 95 non mais allez-y
je voulais se refléter sur tes sûr de
toi moi j'irai à son bon sens mais après
c'est à vous de 300 ch et comme je
mettrais de moi je mets un gros pari
parce qu'on gagne 100 % - si on a parlé
beaucoup alors les en fait les points en
fait j'ai oublié de vous dire on peut
voir les points que vous marquez l'a
donc là si la réponse est bonne vous
marquez 9,9 ou quatre ans au point parce
que il vous permet je suis prêt j'ai
parlé ce machin et sachez que 100 pour
ça est une chanson de david hallyday et
sinon je l'appelle
est ce que c'est votre dernière
pentification c'est comme ça on va
reprendre avec vous son gain de vue à la
chaîne la tronche-en-biais sa réponse un
20 millions réponse de 14 millions
réponse 3 7 millions et réponse 4 10
millions comme ça si tu montes emplettes
à l'adresse se passe après l'appel un
ami elle nie pas les commentaires donc
20 14 sept
après ce moment mais on a fait un 10
points d'un coup on peut dire de moi je
mettrais entre entre 7 et 10 mais c'est
plus sur 17
[Musique]
trente cinq sur dix est sûre le 14 sept
quel probable fait à plus de 100 alors
cessons optimale oui ce sont des maisons
publibook celland manche et entre 10 et
14 mai vraiment du coup j'ai changé
d'avis
d'autant que si on fait moins de 5 sur 7
juin 25 sur cet objectif l amont 14,7 30
- 14 30 sur 40 soit 14 allée parce que
c'est votre dernière quantification
c'est notre marque et 3,1 points donc
peu propres références si vous répondiez
25% vous à toutes les réponses à ce raid
25.3 plus combien de vue à la chaîne
hygiène mentale
7 10 14 épisodes qui a sorti à temps
c'est super chaud en plus si au moins
ils nous mettaient sur une échelle
logarithmique j'entre cent mille 1
millions 10 millions et 100 millions là
ce serait plus simple arrêté quand même
un peu médiatique je crois c'est un peu
profonds 1,5 eur plus que la tranche
enfin moment autant mais non parce qu'il
ya beaucoup moins de deux équipes mais
tous les scores sont additionnés non non
c'est différent vous serez bien aidé par
une vidéo ils ont très bien l'anglais
mais revient décrivant le dsk lui sert
effectivement c'est cette vidéo j'en
sais rien cgc d'estimer il habite en
face à un bond des cobras 208 pour les
20 millions on n'y croit pas domino j'y
crois pas donc 0 10% à 56 % 10 % moi ça
me semble tout est possible là on peut
voir son ps je me tournerai l'ouest
ouais mais on peut être complètement à
l'ouest et 5% s'aggrave ça fait un peu
moins c'est
je compare avec moi la seule chaîne que
je connais et j'ai très bien d'en bas
les visages
je m c'est quoi la réponse c'était les
mêmes pour cette histoire avec les
précédents c'est une proposition
la réponse du coup
[Musique]
est ce pour ça que ça va alterner la
prochaine question à chaque fois les
questions se ressemblent un peu
c'est vrai pour moi je mettrais un max
sur 10 millions on n'a fait que 30 me
pour répondre à une question du parquet
disons 20 % sur 14 dynario % 20 % sur
sept millions et le reste 25 25 14
ça fait combien si je viendrai sur 10
des meilleurs jusqu'à 50% sur du million
ouais suspense est à son comble m 45 %
et 25 25 ici à les autres parce que
c'est à dire complications du coup le
score soit les deux 15 13 face à la
presse nous ça doit vous combien
d'abonnés à la chaîne de michael ii né
mois 60 ans à 450 milles mais ouais il a
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de vent mais
comment place 90 sur 675 ans j'irai pas
autant je connais je suis pas abonné
laisse regarder combien d'abonnés tv les
questions j'aurais dit 500000 clairement
je pense qu'à ce de légaliser 300000
voilà comme je mettrais 0 lui elles sont
1300 villes mais je mettrais peut-être
20 % et 80 %
partons nous en forçant à ce 450 kw ou
six ans mais vraiment et les vieilles sa
chaîne elle marche petite interruption
comme dans les vidéos mcphail carlito
nous avons un nouvel invité les sciences
humaines
[Musique]
techniquement on est quatre et eux ils
sont dus à voir si ces déséquilibres est
ce que c'est votre dernière
interrogation trop des reniements sa
dernière convocation mais dans la
définition de sensibiliser notre nom aux
blacks de 450 me n'a quand même ils ont
perdu 2,8 points 455 me faire des points
[Musique]
combien de v à la chaîne des leviers 230
mille cent cinq mille soixante dix mille
ou cent soixante mille fait partie de
ceux que j'aime bien regarder les stats
des objets graphiques 110-105 ses 160 et
230 cas j'aurais pu dire 70 ça fait
vraiment je parle de ça va très gentil
aussi de prendre le plus bas chiffres
moi j'aurais bien 65 et 160 mes contrats
aux bâtiments aux probabilités il ya
quelqu'un dans le chat qui dit qu' il
l'a peu vu la réponse avant c'était
après 450 toute l'année vous réussi à
arrêter d'être
je sais pas on peut partir sur le champ
du pt entre 70 à 105 4 mai 34 et 37 35
65 35 65
le suspense est à son comble en bien sûr
5 5 et 10 ouais c'est une dernière
quantification ouais pas mal on va se
faire planter chez ces avancées 70000
donc gagné 3,1 points
alors évitez de vous [ __ ] parce que
quand même très sympathique mais à ses
idées oui mais voilà donc tout le monde
et pousse autant que vous la question
proximité c'est pour vous caen a été
créé la chaîne de eureka août 2016
janvier 2015 octobre 2015 8 juin 2010
est bien tout est créé ça veut pas dire
que la première vidéo
cette opération de la chaîne tu peux
créer et à voir la première vidéo défend
un an après
la sortie s'est pas 2015 pour toi c'est
pas deux minutes or moi je n'ai
absolument aucune idée
ben oui moi je mets en route 2016 non
c'est bien de 2016 il valentine on
mettre quelqu'un de constant sur le oui
voilà oui oui sans sur le ring 20% sur
le bric side 40%
ouais 40% sur juin 2010 16 30 pour toi
c'était vraiment pas ce qu'il a créé un
restaurant dont on peut mettre 15 k o
non je mettrais un 10/10 ben ok 10 et 20
derrière quantification au final c'était
octobre 2015 ils ont marqué un point
seulement grâce à votre expérience
on passe maintenant à l'autre le type a
été créé la chaîne de stupide economics
j'adresse 2016 17 juin 2015 ou décembre
c'est à dire anciens je suis quasi sûr
séjour 2015 parmi les propositions avec
un petit peu sera plus de 65 à 35
beaucoup d'annoncés plus sûr que ça
au moins 80 est ce que j'ai fait c'est
que je sais qu est ce qui existait on
j'ai commencé ma chaîne j'ai commencé ma
chaîne en juillet août 2016 et je sais
que ça existe déjà et je pense pas que
ça existait depuis deux mois
beaucoup d'abonnés vous semble donc être
que je connaissais pas si bien il ya
plein doute avec avril 2016
moi je partirai là dessus mais pas plus
que quatre allez on prend le risque de
regagner un peu des points lendemain
évaluer correctement notre notre
croyance parce qu'il n'ya pas de calais
avec chiffres si jamais ça c'est pas la
bonne réponse vous perdez de -6 points à
cause de cette question là du score
vis-à-vis des autres montrez vous avez
2.5 points et les autres disent être
[Musique]
allés
non c'est un jeu qu'au départ lui faut
conquis doctorat le pfl qu'il ya
peut-être des erreurs dans le code aller
75 est ce que c'est votre dernière
quantification y est c'est gagné 8 bi
poin et du coup je prenais a largement
l'avantagé avec quatre points d'avancé
voilà combien à de vue la vidéo sur les
ondulations de cartons de syllabes 62520
ses 140 va beaucoup d'abonnés elle a
plus de 120 me le donner
il a cartonné 50 50 the way suppose
c'est quand même moi ces 249 90
personnes 90% passion mais 80% et
l'apprendre marché ces dernières vidéos
japonais sont très efficaces
nobody marketing 240 habitude 77 90 10
[Musique]
75 25 75 500 anciens particules ag l'un
c'est qu'elle a fait pas chez eux qui
ont bien marché récemment 75 500
applications go way you lie pour
débarquer il vient de vu à la vidéo
les terroristes ont gagné du chat
sceptiques
si même réponse en 240 60 où à peu près
tous les médecins attendent d'être entre
le ch à ce petit jeu il a dépassé les
100 miller
ouais les 110 d'abonnés après est ce
qu'il fait c'est juste la question je
sais pas après elle n'est pas super
ancienne on assure t vu que les faits
comme l'a 40 est et si je devais leur
action tu fais le voile évident qu'en
général je mettrais très peu sur 15% max
sur tout
c'est horrible ce jeu parce qu'on lance
fond nos chances sont là d'accord
franchement ça méritait bien qu'assez
même pas que ça mérite parce qu'en plus
la lgo youtube des fois il met en avant
des trucs cette vidéo band ans et les
bombes à 1 sur 30 15 sur 30 ouais ouais
je pense qu'il a fait beaucoup plus
facile puisque ça moi je dirais 120
mille ans
le tweet sur le sens à 1050 combien 50
sur 220 mille ans après ce genre de type
à ckac et camara donc c'est en gagnant 2
allée oui on part du principe qu'il a
bien fait cellule après cet exposé mme
kouassi gironde 40/15 sur 60 km et
passera à bout bayeux comme je sors ta
vie sinon ça me paraît fort et en plus
c'est un petit jean harvey milk et on
fait gaffe parce qu'on a des micros des
deux côtés du coup si tout le monde
parle en même temps je pense c'est le
bordel à entendre et l'équipe de
monsieur frêche est parce qu apparemment
tu t'appelles comme ça maintenant bien
parce que c'est d'accord
les 25 sur des serveurs 15% sur 70% sur
[Rires]
on aime on l'a surnommé nous chose que
certaines applications
c'est un truc ligue marc fouilles yun
espère maintenant de 24 pour moi c'est
quand même eux qui dominent
[Musique]
prochaine question donc ceux qui comme
combien de dislike à lui convient de dix
lacs à la vidéo de quoi nous protège des
vaccins obligatoires de primum non
nocere
428 856 214 ou sens alors sachez c'est
le nombre de disques naïve a dépassé les
cent mille francs soit françois je
t'aime contrairement à l'orée envie de
mettre tout point au micro par an avant
il ya pas tellement de dislike sur les
sur les vidéos
tiens c'est moi c'est toi qui tu me
parles je ne touche pas c'est un petit
peu l'expert de cette question il ya
cette table ça dépend si ça veut dire
beaucoup vu en pourcentage j'aurais dit
99% est ce qu'elle est beaucoup été vu
il ya plus de sens si ce n'est que je
suis pas sûr n'a jamais faire ça mais vu
la vue dépasser ses vues sur ça donc il
n'aura pas à 856 beasley que je faisais
je dirais pas ça 428 jamais vraiment de
entre 2 114 107 je dirais pas cela
peut-être tendance 214 on en a assez peu
en fait
les probabilités vont commander la vidéo
sur la vaccination que j'ai
habituellement j'ai 99 % de like à peu
près surtout la vidéo sur la vaccination
c'est 97% de like de rapports line is
like serait que les besoins des
caténaires vos commentaires mais
c'est tellement machin non je reste et
je resterai petit mais après surtout
qu'elle est surtout qu'elle est bien
parce que non je touche pas micro de la
peur du pot c'est mon métier c'est ce
qui va s'en vont prendre invités là on
va mettre je mettrais 40 42 1 800
policiers et là du coup il nous reste
conduire à l'essai mais 5,5
parce que c'est votre dernière
quantification je crois en toi françois
intérêts ne pas avoir mis des points
marqués 48.71 alors combien ce derby
cela à la vidéo
les électrices elite électricité verte
selon greenpeace l'écologie dogmatique
du réveil eur 181 4 736 92 ou 368 je
pense parce que elles sont vraiment bien
apprécié du réveil heures et en fin de
compte il n'est pas très regardé je vais
dire à mes jambes en dépit du fait
qu'ils traitent des sujets extrêmement
extrêmement active en bas il est trés
tellement bien c'est tellement sérieuse
mais souvent ça soulève pas tomber avec
sont négatifs même si sans doute sur
celle ci ça tire pas trop les
détracteurs il des gens 50 minutes 50
cent mille
du coup 50% sur saint jeanne 25 jours
les deux suivantes
ouais
tu mettrais plus sur l'être puissance
mais quel est l'effet d'ancrage de la
question précédente
moi j'aurais bien dit plus que 50
surtout 60-60 coûte
on a un peu d'avancé à imposer le
permettre on peut faire de la merde on
peut gérer une avance
je suis désolé mais c'est quoi les
discussions les arguments qu'on peut
apporter soit on a des vraies
informations soit on fait au filet de
passes 10 sec n'est pas moi je suis
sioniste avait donc pour fait chaud la
sirène moi je propose 60 % sur 86 pour y
aller quoi mais c'est plutôt sur ta
chaîne qui voilà la réponse quand tu
nous présentera ce jeu donc bon on n'est
pas en question la le temps passe
mon éducation j'ai fait perdre des
points 0 4 0 et 20 attention c'est au
var non non non bertrand cet exode est
rare c'est une explication aux oscars
nous avoue qu'elle est là vidéos de
balades mental qui a le plus de vues cas
soit 438 ans par seconde le calendrier
cosmique et de carl sagan les planètes
et r disparu voyage dans l'infiniment
grand
trouver la date de votre mort
bibliothèque de babel
j'ai une grosse intuition sur la
troisième voyage dans l'infini mango oui
mais elle a très bien fonctionné comme
mon avis c'est lequel plus de vue elle
d'être plus anciennes il suffit que tu
es un gros boum sur une et au grand
paris mais qu'elle n'est pas une ville
qui s'appelle comme ça l est pas si
récente que ça un voyage vers l'infini
c'est pas une de celles des derniers on
va de quatre cent trente huit ans par
seconde à les plus récentes je pense je
m'en tire bien que des lieux deux
versions voilà donc pour cela il ya eu
deux versions aussi en fait et ça
s'arrête là vieille solidaire je pense
que les deux seul que je connaisse c'est
celle là celle là c'était la 1ère à la
3ème du coup les déférer devant toi ce
que tu dis ça mais ça m'étonnerait pas
que ce soit celle ci j'ai conversé c'est
parce que je sais quoi
l'infiniment grand quelle probabilité
d'une hausse bien moins intuitive manche
rémy genre 40-30 qui répartit entre les
deux derniers grands comptes avec
l'allemande de micro 40 sur la troisième
trente et trente 30 sur la pelouse est à
130% 15 et 15,5 avec injection de grande
qualité
le suspense est à son comble quoique
attend les planétaire disparu le 5 %
fait des paris de ce parfum comme omar
sharif les courses ma grande taille et
du coût 45 et 21-17 choque pas trop
thibault qui n'ont peut-être que la
risée influençant saint girons une petit
paris berceau c'est que ce côté l
essentiel et jeudi celle que la démarche
est aussi née bref allez mon cd la
quantification parce que rendre ça à un
média pas aux prochaines élections
c'est quoi le site pour les cuisses n'y
a pas de site pour le quizz apparemment
le mettra peut-être je vais mettre en
lien dans les commentaires et sur
twitter il
[Musique]
12 microns quelle est la vidéo de zeste
de sciences qui a le plus de vues des
poissons économes en énergie de la glace
dans le champagne la science des ballons
comment ne pas renverser sa bière sait
que trop bien mais moi c'est très bien
mais la science des ballons je crois que
c'est une des plus anciennes donc il ya
des chances qu'elles soient bien vu
aussi bas vous lui demandez là
spontanément passé mais après je sais je
sais ah bah du coup monsieur youtube dit
que la peau qui a découvert la chaîne de
restauration c'était grâce aux poissons
mohamed 35 % de chez vous ouais je pense
quand 5% sur les poissons et envers sur
un an comme sur rien regarde on peut
monter à 100% par tous les sondés
pensent que c'est chaud vous vous
perdrez plus de françois mercier
mais ça l'est ont fait 35 35 et 15 et
puis voilà les dernières quantification
josé base en quatre questions suivantes
abonnez vous parce que les brewers quel
est le ratio like sur vu de la vidéo sur
la contagion du suicide d'elixis pullis
macroscopique alors ratio light
c'est ouais mais quand c'est des sujets
à un peu impactant être un prix ça le
concerne un peu c'est triste les gens
s'engagent on à ses attentes et vue sur
lie que j'ai vu sur like d'accord t'as
des fonds pour du régime et donc 4 vu
pour un like 16 vu pour un like 64 vue
prend like ou 256 vue pour nike
[Musique]
probabilité
5 % sur quatre ça fait vraiment un gros
engagement 956 cela consiste à toi je
suis trop absorbés ils étaient 1200 56
il nous reste 20 points positionning la
tâte gaz augmente de 5 64 ou c'est
peut-être à dany doucet but et après on
assiste à un taux de fidélisation et un
taux d'engagement qui reste fort donc je
voudrais plutôt que sur 16 que 40 40 go
64 au même niveau
vas-y on voyait 16 de côté quel est le
ratio but sur like ne sait pas à qui
sont bien posées sur like we gens de la
vidéo sur le coronavirus de tania lui
nos récentes d'ailleurs j'ai vu la vidéo
intégrale ipad vécu sa main au bout d'un
moment peut-être que le ratio bâle aura
pas beaucoup de si c'est pas des abonnés
début de saison après celle de l'actus
appelé
et m ouais donc moi aussi
ouais 20 et 80 peut-être 24 ya ça
m'étonnerait pas que ce soit 80 parce
que justement si c'est des personnes qui
sont pas abonnés qui sont pas sur
youtube c'est comme c'est un truc
d'actualité
je m de plus urbain que 80 moi je serai
plus sur quatre chocs sur casse en droit
que sont déjà ou jezzine 50 50 50 50
le 320 on est d'accord que les gens
soient très pour faire le touriste en
temps de regarder dans l'eau de qu'est
ce que tu dis qu shield et dukey salut
tout le monde
moi c'est mon mauvais plus monsieur fidh
de la chaîne suffit qu'une action j'ai
55 ans des occasions ça vous convient
j'aurais du mal à conserver deux autres
allez donc ça nous va vous
alors quel est le titre de la deuxième
vidéo avec le plus de vues
bille de sciences le vide comment
montrer la présence de l'air distinguer
l'ère du vide de mise en évidence de
l'air il me semble une de celles sur les
deux êtres david doivent qui le fait
m'étonnerait pas que c'était une des
premières
ce ne serait pas qu'elle ait fait un max
a mis la deuxième vidéo deuxième vidéo
avec le plus de vues j'avoue relation
mais 25 partout sur celle là
la branche est techniquement les titres
sont j'ai l'impression que l'air et le
vide sont des trucs un peu fort sur che
non non je pense qu'a expliqué le vide à
des enfants c'est un peu bizarre savez
tous la mise en mini vans de l'air je
viens la vidéo de dailymotion qui
faisait qui faisait des expériences avec
de l'eau comme ça en versant de jeu
l'air dans l'eau pour france bazzo d'un
récit pure et l'autre j'espère que tous
ces mets 4 pour moi mais il y en a mais
les bateaux c'est la deuxième plus
grosse c'est bidon alors si on a
l'habitude par une puce sur les nôtres
parce que je sais c'est tout des vidéos
dont celle ainsi trois accords le groupe
a donc en fait c'est pas des titres de
vidéos tous tout à fond ce sont pas des
petites de vidéos d'accord folie mais le
vrai jean c'est pour ça qu'on comprenait
par les questions et tant qu'elle est là
pour moi ce serait donc ok donc je vois
la vidéo en question c'est plutôt c'est
un truc sur l'air que la présence de
l'air je pense que c'est comment montrer
la présence de l'air moi c'est 2004 et
peut-être un peu et 4,5 à 7 e les 4 50
j'ai une petite préférence pour comment
montrer
ils ont bien sûr vous avez peut-être
60/40 pur 60 40
oui c'est possible c'est possible si
vous manque un papa qui a le poignet
arthur c'était le dernier à pratiquer à
sion nom de la sicile clairement une
question vide la presse que c'est dans
le titre je sais pas mais oui c'est une
question vide je sais pas ce qui se
passe à ma droite mais c'est intéressant
du coup forcément 5% tous à 560 peut
rejoindre l'autre équipe mais jamais
dans l'équipe du monde qu'on vous
présente
alice qui va s'en aller alice au pays
des étoiles très bonne celle attendue
elle annonce que les gens qui sont là
vous êtes ami pas passer le micro
oui alors eu la formation micron est ce
que c'est les extrémités des
demi-cercles les de quoi parle-t-on
moelleux derrière toi tu viens juste
partout quantification de mire avec
cathy trévaux nous et marqué trois
points 4 par an donc c'était bien un
truc 3 que c'était un mauvais tir
[Rires]
la mise en mots les titres aussi la
présence de la vidéo avec le plus de vue
de l'église orsys cannabis expliqué en
six minutes
réponse 2 le cannabis est il comparable
à l'alcool réponse 3 réponse un cannabis
et géologie même pas à l'esprit sorties
font des trucs en six minutes ou pas
[Musique]
[Rires]
démerdez vous non je pense que en fait
c'est le même titre c'est cinq fois
votre juste trouver le bon titre
oui c'est ça moi j'aurais dit cannabis
est comment faut-il interdire le
cannabis je dirais j'ai fait un petit
quelle probabilité
enfin le pire c'est que j'ai vu cette
vidéo fin j'ai vu le titre est tout
voilà voilà les canadiens
[Musique]
j'aurais bien livre donc un ami
s'expliquer en six minutes
ça paraît un peu prosélyte quand même
sur un truc est quand même globalement
illégal intéressant c'est pas prosélyte
c'est juste un site à cliquer
rexel a décidé d'arrêter juste à cliquer
sur les 22 derniers faute et interdire
le cannabis est que la ville de tadmaït
combattre entre les valeurs qu'elle
prouve à boubou combat par site
moi je moi je l'espère oui c'est sûr en
six minutes de jeu
peut-être [ __ ] à 5% sur le premier
juste pour ma dignité
[Rires]
on va faire comme toi je sers quant aux
40 bla et puis voilà mais le 3 ils vont
pas faire ça faut-il interdire le
cannabis tu vois dans ce prix sorcier
cannabis et avant même combat ça ne
paraîtrait l'esprit des spacer's ils ont
comme ça parce que vous faut-il
interdire le cannabis serait les
classiques je viens moi je ne vois bien
jamie se fumait un joint en transit et
l'opa buts entre 1,4 et moi je mettrais
20,86 c'était moi entre 24 24 20 et 80
moi c'est ce que je ferai mais moi je
suis tout seul
à partir du moment où tu as raison que
vraiment on est avec toi dans le jeu si
mme valentine toi et tes regards sur moi
je suis un grand c par contre si tu te
plantes on a joué dans l'épave jeu
la vue lui mais je me dis ça m'excite
récents être dans l'illégalité dans le
respect le plus total
les effets du cannabis en soi dieu vous
perdez de 2,10 points leur vécu la
dernière dernière vidéo
caen a été publié la vidéo comment se
propage les rues alors stop de floch
fiche jeu les chronos dans le premier à
chaque science j'ai dû sortir le truc en
juin 2018 donc c'était au moins sorti à
ce moment allez je me sens sur février
2018 ancrant valentine attend en 2020
donc c'est en 2019
c'était avant ou après le peuvent
largement avant juillet 2019 donc je
pense a vendu à peu près 6 % du contrat
mais pour moi je met 100 % à l'ego
niveau des scores c'est d'être en quart
de point e
on est à 51 points qui peuvent guider
il gagne soyons bilan a été publié la
vidéo un singe escale londres barcelone
attention alors je pense que c'était en
septembre
c'est que dès septembre on a une
question c'est quelle année 2015 2016
je pense qu'on peut mettre 25 partout il
est très sympa je mettrais 0 5% sur
septembre 2015
je pense pas que c'était en 2000 que
c'est une série qui est plus personne ne
mérite pas le port de moi j'aurais
tendance à plus faire confiance à 2017
étrange escale c'est pas les premiers
trucs qu'il a fait sur sa chaîne du coup
c'est relativement récent oui ils vous
2010 et dont deux semblent plus
probables
moi je mettrais 60% sur septembre 2010 7
20% sur 2016 20 % sur 2010 2016 et 2018
plutôt qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais
bon c'est vrai que c'est peut-être
peut-être plus 2018 ont peu baissé
peut-être 2016 et à dominante
alimentaire un peu 2018 vers 15 % le
premier 50 % et 35 % 5
le mec qui joue au jeu cette dernière
interrogation est ce que ça vous va
elles finissent à 47 points
car il était complètement
on aurait dit m 25 ans et seagate sa
délinquance
il me semblait qu'il avait commencé
cette série à
après londres savait pas c'est
invraisemblable voilà alors voilà c'est
fini donc le score final est de 46 47 06
contre 44,5
l'équipe 2 pour méditer quand même une
belle partie 1 précisons le
l'histoire était serré et on a fait des
scores assez assez mauvais quand même si
on le sait ça c'est mieux que répondre
25% à toutes les réponses que il ya des
progrès à faire en terme de rayonnement
bayésiens c'est quoi le 25 % à toutes
les réponses le hasard sûrement on est à
peine mieux que le hasard mais je pense
que les questions étaient assez mauvaise
je pense qu'on peut le dire les voilà
bravo allait bientôt pour qui veut
gagner des crédences et entend faire des
crédences un dernier mot fabulous mais
les crédences c'est pas le truc que tu
mets les analystes
mais quel est le rapport dans le
contexte